that how do we identify the holy spirit
in someone else all right
you shall know them matthew 7 14-18 we
shall know them by their fruits
now we know from galatians 5 verse 22 23
but the fruit of the spirit is love
joy peace long-suffering gentleness
goodness
faith meekness temperance those are the
fruits but there's uh
the fruits must be combined with the
gifts
there are two different things the
fruits will be eternal the gifts will
come to an end
in the new world they don't need we
don't need the gift of healing we don't
need to give the prophecy the gifts are
temporary
the fruits are eternal but they work
together one of the gifts according to
first corinthians 12 8-10
is discerning of spirits
because we know from second corinthians
11 14
satan is transformed into an angel of
light
therefore it is not no great thing if
his ministers
also are transformed into the ministers
of righteousness
error can be so close to truth you
cannot tell the difference unless you
have
a refined understanding of god's word
and so we need
the spirit of discernment to realize no
no no
no this is not true light it is light
but it is
not true light and so along with the
study of the word of god
we develop the spirit of discernment
because deception you keep in mind
the devil deceived perfect unfallen
angels he deceived them
and according to ellen white it was only
up until the cross
when some angels saw what satan did to
christ that they finally broke off all
sympathy with him
what i'm saying is this perfect angels
for thousands of years
still felt that satan had been badly
treated so deception
is a very powerful thing we combat it
with the word of god and obedience
as we do that we develop the spirit of
discernment
to decide this is not of god i may not
have scientific evidence
but i discern now parents will
understand what i'm saying
here comes a young lady she brings a
young man to the family
and the father chats with a young man
for a while and
discerns without any proof this young
man is no good
he's a demon in suit he is no good or
the young man brings a young lady to the
family the mother meets with the young
lady
and the mother comes away and she has
discerned
this young lady is as lazy as whatever
and so discernment is not based on
scientific evidence
it is something we develop in our study
of god's word
and continual obedience to him and so we
identify
someone is led by the spirit by thus
saith the lord
and also by that internal power of
discerning
and the power of discernment is the
spirit himself speaking to you
when ananias and sapphira came to uh
peter
just to give him the money of having saw
some land in acts chapter five
they both lie peter knew they lied
because the spirit gave him that power
of discernment
we need it and it is one of the things
lacking in the church
we have no discernment inside that style
of dress is wrong
that kind of music is wrong that kind of
behavior is wrong we don't have that
discernment
because we don't study the word of god
but discernment is a gift the church
needs
and it works along so we have the fruits
and we have the gifts and one of the
gifts is discernment
and that will identify if someone is of
god or not
but there are certain obvious things you
can see but the things that are not
obvious
the spirit of discernment will make them
clear to the child of god
amen and i completely agree with you
elder skeet because even
as you study the word of god and your
life
transforms with the work of the holy
spirit within you you start even
analyzing and of seeing everything that
you watched all the movies that you
watched it everyone at secular watching
like whoa
can't watch all the music that's secular
you will easily be able to know whoa
this was evil i didn't even notice this
before
but now it's now it's being exposed to
you right in front of your eyes
absolutely so definitely powerful for
that and so i loved what you said
that gifts that god has given us all
with the church
that is temporal but the fruit of the
spirit is
permanent permanent and that is
something that we see a lot of churches
they
emphasize so much attention on you have
to have if you have to have this gift
you
that's right okay
so uh let us go into the next question
and this is actually one of the gifts
that i
i believe a lot of individuals
misunderstand and they
heavily promote
you